Anesh, from India, asks:
What are some of the aspects that go into
building a practical Real World search engine
and how should you use existing tools,
such as preexisting libraries, to help build your search engine?
So one example he gives in his post,
which has a lot of great deal in there--and I encourage people to look at it--
is Beautiful Soup,
which is a Python library to parse really complicated HTML.
So in our web crawler, we just parse
very strict, kind of string match,
and it doesn't always follow that rule so Beautiful Soup can help with that.
Should we be aware of these libraries, and how should we include them?
Yeah--so there's a lot of things that are more complicated
if you want to build a robust search engine
that's going to work on all the pages out there on the Web.
And Anesh has a good list of some of the things that you need to think about,
and for the advanced students that are wanting to go beyond
what we're doing in class, it's great to start thinking about those things.
And it is also the case that you don't want to build everything yourself.
In this class, we're building things ourselves because
we want to learn what's going on underneath
and build as much and understand as much about computing as we can.
If you're building Real software, you want to try to start from libraries
that other people have already written that are available for you to use
and Beautiful Soup is a very useful library for parsing HTML--
for doing the kinds of things that get real complicated,
if you want to find links in Real HTML code
that can be much more complex than what we're focusing on so far.
It's still using the same kinds of ideas that we do in the class,
but someone else has put a lot of effort into writing that code
and making it work, and it's definitely a good idea to reuse libraries that are available.
You have to check, carefully, what the license is on those libraries--
whether you can use them or not.
But it's definitely--when you start building more complex programs,
rather than starting from scratch and writing everything yourself,
trying to find a library that will help you get what you need done more quickly
is a great idea.